la picardie cette ancienne province qui
n'a jamais pu se donner à un seul
département et qui a voulu appartenir à
4 connaît dans cette précocité dans la
tanière une beauté calme et solide
[Musique]
le ciel ils possèdent des reflets
profond peut être provoquée par les
mille et un miroir des rivières et des
canaux et quand une caméra s'amuse à
découvrir la poésie sans autre but que
de mettre en images la rime des tons et
les alexandrins de l'harmonie et bien
alors
la picardie est merveilleuse
expliquez-nous yannick jadot en quoi
cette région et ses paysages forme ou
forge un caractère
mais la région de juin dans l'aisne
c'est une région agricole c'est une
région de ruralité c'est vrai que lee
compris moi mon grand-père était paysan
dans la tirage c'était vraiment les les
toutes petites fermes
c'était dur donc c'est un rapport à la
terre qui vraiment très profond qui est
ça fait partie de la vie ça fait partie
de la forte sont des forêts qui sont
magnifiques véritablement magnifique la
forêt de saint-gobain et d'autre alors
je sais pas ces images viennent
peut-être du vimeu en tout cas plus du
côté de la somme
et puis c'est un patrimoine historique
incroyable un parfait un patrimoine
architectural
moi ma ville de
là où j'ai j'ai été à l'école c'est laon
dans l'aisne c'est
ccd église c'est une cathédrale c'est
sont des remparts c'est une ville
absolument magnifique et puis
aujourd'hui
c'est beaucoup de difficultés sociales
désertification des des services publics
donc c'est une terre rude c'est une
terre absolument magnifique et fait
partie de ma vie parce que c'est le plus
beau pays du monde et est-ce qu'un
picard pudique et capable de fendre
l'armure pour faire un bon candidat à la
présidentielle je sais pas ce qu'est un
bon candidat à l'élection présidentielle
en tout cas j'espère que c'est d'abord
quelqu'un qui dans les propositions dont
le projet réponde à la fois aux
difficultés du quotidien parce que
nos compatriotes en connaissent beaucoup
et puis qui accompagnent leurs
aspirations parce que la vie ça n'est
pas que des difficultés c'est des
aspirations individuelles et puis c'est
un projet c'est un projet pour la france
une élection présidentielle c'est s'est
passé d'une d'un pan du passé au futur
j'allais dire c'est ouvrir une nouvelle
page un nouveau chapitre de l'histoire
de france et quand on est piqué on a les
pieds sur terre il ya une forme de bon
sens de rationalité on a les pieds dans
la terre et je pense qu'on n'a jamais eu
autant besoin que de retrouver le lien
avec la terre avec la nature
[Musique]